[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de pas
vous allez poser une question
essentielle pour les pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les gens qui
cherchent un emploi les autres prises
ont-elles besoin des réseaux sociaux et
si oui bah comment peuvent-elles accéder
sur quel réseau sociaux comment faire
est-ce qu'il faut se former toute une
série de questions auxquelles vous allez
répondre grâce à vous Virginie fait
bonjour
vous êtes la présidente et la fondatrice
de star tag c'est ça
on trouve de formation notamment aux
réseaux sociaux au réseau sociaux
spécialisé dans l'apprentissage du
numérique oui absolument ça fait une
quinzaine d'années
finalement depuis depuis la fin de mes
études
et vous faites vous êtes aussi
conférencière et vous êtes la codrice
d'un livre dont on avait déjà parlé ici
stratégie et marketing
avec avec Maëlys bulk exactement
fin 2022
et dans lequel on parle notamment en
effet des réseaux sociaux pas seulement
exactement pour démarrer sa stratégie
numérique absolument
Pierre Olivier far bonjour
vous êtes spécialiste de marketing vous
êtes enseignant le SCE Business School
et vous êtes le vous avez dirigé un
flotteur de plusieurs ouvrages mais on
va en parler en particulier et que vous
avez dirigé qui s'appelle
l'entrepreneuriat
dans lequel vous avez interrogé
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de chefs
d'entreprise de jeunes chefs
d'entreprise et de ce de ce livre vous
avez tiré un article qui est paru dans
ce sur le site un excellent site qui
s'appelle de conversation qui est aussi
tout des universitaires souvent traitent
des problèmes actuels et vous avez
publié un article sur justement LinkedIn
et les entreprises
absolument comment aujourd'hui linkedIn
est perçu par les entrepreneurs et
comment peuvent-ils arriver à utiliser
tous les atouts de ce réseau social pour
développer leur business la finalité
qu'il recherche alors on verra peut-être
avec Virginie à d'autres aussi
et puis Melvin Platel bonjour bonjour
vous êtes chargé de mission à la CPME 78
donc c'est très intéressant on va on va
parler avec Olivier Givart de la
création d'entreprise dit qu'il y a un
million d'entreprises qui se sont créés
dans les dernières années dans ces
entreprises il y a beaucoup de petites
ou de très petites entreprises et c'est
évidemment votre secteur d'action et
dans votre job à la CPME vous avez vu
que les réseaux sociaux sont absolument
essentiels pour ces entreprises tout à
fait c'est vrai que depuis que j'ai pris
mon job en tant que Chargé de mission je
me rends compte que beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs et même nous-mêmes qui
accompagnons les entreprises sont sur
les réseaux sociaux en partie du colin
aussi
dans l'article de the conversation vous
vous dites il y a un peu plus d'un
million d'entreprises qui ont été créés
c'est le site de l'INSEE
en 2022 et encore c'est en 2022
il y a aussi
il y a aussi des entreprises qui qui
malheureusement ferment leur porte voilà
mais on arrive dans un secteur tellement
concurrentiel qu'il faut savoir se faire
connaître absolument alors se faire
connaître c'est une bonne question parce
qu'on aurait tendance à se dire il y a
les réseaux sociaux je fonce dans les
réseaux sociaux mais finalement pour y
faire quoi
quand on regarde le nombre aujourd'hui
d'utilisateurs sur Linkedin alors j'ai
regardé avant de venir j'ai révisé mes
fiches on parle de 26 millions d'abonnés
sur Linkedin en France dont alors on
relativise il y a 13 millions
aujourd'hui d'utilisateurs dit actifs
tous les mois mais comment je vais
arriver en étant entrepreneur en ayant
certainement une bonne idée un bon
produit à me différencier des autres et
faire en sorte que
j'écris faire un profil sans cesse faire
c'est comme finalement faire un CV mais
est-ce que un CV permet d'avoir un
emploi tout seul non LinkedIn si je ne
fais que mon profil et bien je resterai
avec un joli profil et peut-être une
belle photo mais j'irai pas plus loin et
donc premier thème de cette émission
c'est l'entreprise face aux réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
dans ce livre sur l'entrepreneuriat vous
avez donc interrogé je crois 17 chefs
d'entreprise c'est quoi leur réaction
leur réaction ils sont unanimes sur une
chose il faut être sur Linkedin alors
sur d'autres réseaux sociaux aussi mais
celui qui est le dénominateur commun
Céline l'entreprise pour l'entreprise
tous les objectifs de l'entreprise
l'entrepreneur rassurer se rendre
visible trouver des clients un travail
sa marque employeur enfin il y a pas
mieux il y a pas mieux aujourd'hui c'est
un peu la base la base pour même
construire exactement
on peut pas on peut pas passer outre de
Linkedin quand on a une entreprise que
ce soit comme Virginie a dit pour la
visibilité c'est quand même quelque
chose de très important alors on verra
après tout à l'heure si on y a d'autres
réseaux sociaux et lesquels et sur
lesquels les entrepreneurs peuvent aller
donc les réactions de ces 17
entrepreneurs il faut y être après si on
leur commence à leur demander comment
eux ils sont allés
on se rend compte que la plupart du
temps c'est assez désorganisé c'est j'ai
commencé par faire mon profil et puis je
me suis dit tiens je vais commencer à
publier de l'information et j'étais déçu
parce que j'avais pas de retour sur
l'information que je publiais ah j'ai
peut-être pas beau aussi beaucoup
d'utilisateurs qui venaient sur mon
profil donc pas beaucoup d'abonnés donc
je vais essayer de générer des abonnés
mais générer des abonnés c'est prendre
des contacts
etc etc donc finalement on se rend
compte quand on reprend cette
information que le premier point c'est
quel est l'objectif ok il faut être sur
Linkedin mais pour faire quoi il y en a
certains qui vont vous dire moi j'ai
objectif derrière de lancer une
opération de financement participatif
sur mon entreprise donc il faut que je
communique il faut que je me fasse
connaître il faut que je donne
l'information qui donne aussi envie aux
personnes de souscrire à mon projet et
de me rejoindre et d'autres il faut que
je prenne et je prenne des rendez-vous
c'est un outil de prospection je dois
prendre des rendez-vous et ça ça veut
dire il faut que je repère entre
guillemets que je cible
personne les entreprises à adressé mais
le point de départ vraiment l'objectif
qu'ils veulent atteindre exactement
Virginie évidemment confirmer ça vous
parlera peut-être après justement des
peut-être des besoins de formation parce
que comme dit Pierre-Olivier voilà on
peut être sur le nid mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et c'est vrai que définir
d'abord
la raison pour laquelle on veut être sur
les réseaux sociaux et ce qu'on veut y
dire c'est essentiel déjà une cible je
crois que souvent on a tendance à
oublier qu'il faut bien cibler pour son
réseau pour ses postes parce que on peut
pas parler à tout le monde c'est par la
personne donc il faut savoir à qui on
s'adresse et ensuite effectivement il
faut savoir quel message on veut
partager et ces messages-là va falloir
les inclure dans les postes pour savoir
qu'est-ce que je veux transmettre comme
valeur comme vision comme comme atout et
c'est vrai que je l'observe aussi chez
beaucoup de personnes qui nous
contactent souvent c'est un peu c'est un
peu confus tout le monde va dans tous
les sens j'ai pas j'ai pas effectivement
je fais pas de conversion avec mes
postes
alors quand la stratégie est bien rodée
elle est définie dès le démarrage après
c'est hyper fluide et ça fonctionne très
bien donc faut simplement bien réfléchir
à sa stratégie parce que ça se passe
aussi sur le profil quels sont les mots
clés que je vais utiliser en fonction
évidemment du vocabulaire massible
comment ils vont me trouver comment ils
vont me chercher qu'est-ce qui va
résonner en eux quand je vais pouvoir
écrire quels sont la quelle est la
relation qu'ils attendent de moi enfin
bref donc c'est des questions qu'il faut
se poser au préalable avant de se lancer
tête baissée puis surtout ensuite de se
décourager parce que le problème c'est
que les personnes
LinkedIn là pour que ça fonctionne si on
parle de contenu donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle une barn marketing ça veut dire
créer du contenu et faire venir les gens
à soi il faut de la régularité ça veut
dire que si vous faites pas vos deux
postes par semaine au minimum ça va être
compliqué de créer du lien de la
récurrence de rassurer finalement
d'avoir cette cette visibilité et donc
il y a une voie de temps en temps comme
ça ça sert à rien quoi c'est en fait
comme tout canal de communication ça se
réfléchit et il faut de la répétition
pour de la mémorisation pour créer du
lien etc donc faut aussi et pour ça il
faut savoir ce que je vais ce que je
vais raconter comment je vais le dire à
quelle fréquence et surtout pas lâcher
l'affaire parce que soit on voit des
entrepreneurs qui se découragent au bout
d'un mois qui ne fonctionnait pas
j'arrête en fait non il faut continuer
c'est voilà c'est un peu votre
diagnostic aussi c'est le diagnostic
exactement et la prise de conscience
c'est que c'est un vrai job c'est une
vraie mission de l'entrepreneur du chef
d'entreprise de communiquer de prendre
le temps de faire et alors ça quand on
est dans l'entrepreneuriat le temps
c'est son pire ennemi comment je vais
m'organiser et combien de temps alors on
va voir après peut-être qu'il faut
engager des gens ça dépend évidemment
des entreprises parce que sur les 1
million d'entreprises créées
aussi c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
micro-entreprises
d'auto-entrepreneur ou de gens qui
travaillent ou à deux personnes avec
très peu de personnel
du nombre de salariés si vous voulez
générer des contrats si vous voulez
générer de la visibilité il faut prendre
du temps pour justement être visible sur
les réseaux alors il y en a qui sont
plutôt détournés sur de la vente et
d'autres sur de la visibilité comme
comme LinkedIn mais je pense que moins
d'une heure par jour quand on est
entrepreneur c'est difficile pour avoir
un minimum de visibilité je sais pas ce
que ce que vous en pensez quand on
commence à prendre le pli ça va plus
vite une fois qu'on a certains
pour rédiger leur poste donc
ça fait partie aussi des mœurs mais
c'est vrai que tout dépend ce qu'on veut
dire ce qui est sûr c'est que déléguer
au démarrage si on parle de cette
question de déléguer c'est compliqué
aussi parce que on démarre qu'est-ce
qu'achète le client quand une entreprise
démarre à détail très petite elle achète
la personne elle achète ses valeurs elle
achète sa personnalité elle achète la
confiance en elle et parler de ses
propres valeurs c'est difficile de le
dire de le faire dire par quelqu'un
d'autre au démarrage en tout cas après
on arrive à le structurer etc
il faut il faut un peu se mettre à nu
quand on est sur les réseaux sociaux
mais on va en parler je voulais Melvin
peut-être voilà vous avez beaucoup de
petites et de bonnes entreprises qui
sont dans votre de nos Confédération
c'est quoi leur demande justement est-ce
que vous avez beaucoup de demandes sur
est-ce que je devrais aller sur les
réseaux sociaux sur lesquels qu'est-ce
que je dois faire comment alors c'est
vrai que les réseaux sociaux c'est un
peu un sujet à la mode qui s'arrêtera
jamais j'ai envie de dire et c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise
qui réfléchissent à se dire sur quel
réseau je vais aller ce que je vais
aller sur facebook twitter linkedin
l'incontournable c'est le LinkedIn et
c'est vrai que pour répondre à ces
demandes là on a pas mal de choses qui
sont mises en place c'est des ateliers
avec du coup enfin on va dire des
personnes qui souhaitent soit présenter
leur expertise sur le domaine tel que
Virginie qui m'a aussi formé sur le
domaine de LinkedIn et du coup ça leur
apporte vraiment une expertise qui
puisse en fait avoir les tenants ils
aboutissants de ce réseau social et
savoir exactement quoi faire quoi
publier comment faire sous quelle forme
donc c'est vrai que ce sujet là est une
est une demande assez récurrente on va
dire
depuis quelques temps je suppose oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que du coup
il y en a qui ont des résultats suite à
toutes ces demandes là et du coup bah
c'est ça fait venir tout simplement et
des personnes qui se disent ah oui je
devrais peut-être m'y intéresser c'est
quelque chose de pertinent pour moi donc
c'est sûr c'est sûr alors on va revenir
justement à la communication sur
Linkedin mais avant je voudrais
peut-être faire une parenthèse parlons
parler des réseaux sociaux de façon
générale et c'est ce thème il y a
LinkedIn il y a les autres et virginité
vous allez nous expliquer
lesquels peuvent être finalement assez
favorables aux entreprises LinkedIn et
les autres
[Musique]
d'autres évidemment d'autres réseaux
sociaux il y a le plus ancien que
Facebook enfin qui était Facebook c'est
plus maintenant différemment
il y a Twitter
il y a après TikTok il y en a plein moi
j'y connais pas grand chose mais vous
voulez connaissez bien vous dites pour
les entreprises LinkedIn c'est quand
même number one ça c'est sûr que ce soit
pour du bitoussi ou du B2B puisque c'est
la question qu'on nous pose souvent je
m'adresse à des particuliers est-ce que
j'ai intérêt à être sur Linkedin oui ça
rassure oui derrière des professionnels
il y a quand même des humains et donc il
y a des particuliers qui consomment et
une très belle cible donc dans tous les
cas LinkedIn c'est pour moi le premier
pied important ensuite
les gens évidemment le réseau nécessite
aussi une certaine tenue quand même même
si on commence à voir quelques haters
qui viennent sur les fils de discussion
qui viennent commenter
en gros mais enfin sur Twitter on peut
trouver n'importe quoi des gens qui
disent tout et n'importe quoi sur
Linkedin ça me semble un peu plus
sérieux mais voilà c'est peut-être une
appréciation comme ça de l'extérieur oui
encore qu'on voit une évolution dans les
postes aujourd'hui sur Linkedin on
partage quand même beaucoup sa vie
privée ça commence à venir parce que
donc on en parlera plus tard mais en se
mettant à nu on met une partie de sa vie
personnelle et quelle est la limite de
mettre à nu sa vie personnelle pour
servir son entreprise c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui sert son entreprise et
qu'est-ce qui dessert il y a des
influenceurs qui sont dans les top Voice
et super ils ont des portées enfin des
visibilité incroyables mais qui ne
convertissent jamais parce qu'en fait à
force de juste partager le quotidien ou
leurs angoisses ou leur vie perso ça
convertit pas finalement donc ça attire
l'attention mais ça n'atteint pas
l'objectif business donc faut aussi en
tout cas bien calibrer sa stratégie et
savoir ce qu'on dit est-ce qu'on dit pas
et sur les réseaux sociaux alors si on
met à part LinkedIn donc numéro 1 après
vous diriez quoi
tout dépend encore une fois l'objectif
évidemment il y a des réseaux qui sont
plus visuels que d'autres comme
Instagram comme Tik Tok pour Tik Tok
pour la vidéo mais en termes de
conversion évidemment on a des taux
d'engagement sur Linkedin qui dépassent
les deux.80 les taux d'engagement c'est
le nom d'interactions sur un poste par
rapport à la visibilité donc c'est assez
impressionnant là où Facebook vous avez
une plus forte audience mais le taux
d'interaction est beaucoup enfin le taux
d'engagement est beaucoup plus faible
donc après c'est ce qu'on veut dire et
la durée de vie d'un poste aussi la
durée de vie d'un poste sur LinkedIn est
bien plus forte que sur des réseaux
comme facebook qui sont plus éphémères
en tout cas le poste de va vite
s'éteindre et se noyer dans la masse des
postes donc après il y a pas de il y a
pas de mauvais canaux il y a une
stratégie en fonction d'une cible qu'on
veut toucher en fonction d'un objectif
en fonction des formats qu'on veut
partager photo texte vidéo etc et puis
après il y a surtout le piège c'est pas
de se dire je veux être un peu partout
et puis être un peu partout c'est pareil
c'est être un peu nulle part et donc il
vaut mieux centrer sur quelques réseaux
et bien des exploiter en fonction et
définir une stratégie de toute manière
si on en parlait tout à l'heure on
définit une cible et on définit un plan
d'action numérique et donc on inclut
certains réseaux par rapport à cette
cible et le message qu'on va partager
pourquoi
alors c'est une bonne question à
l'époque nous on avait Viadeo c'était
quand même le réseau
et c'est vrai que on était tous sur
Viadeo avec une offre qui était pas
chère d'ailleurs en Premium et
finalement on vient de où c'est fait
français
c'est un peu le ministère finalement on
était très forts
les autres et un peu tôt c'est vrai et
après il y a d'autres initiatives comme
Bill aussi là
[Musique]
c'est pour trouver des emplois c'est un
rapport avec l'entreprise c'est vrai
c'est vrai que ça a été longtemps le
réseau pour aller chercher un emploi
c'est vrai que nous on l'exploite avec
un atelier qu'on a créé qui s'appelle
qui veut être mon boss et effectivement
on forme ça parce que ça c'est très
intéressant parce que on va reparler des
chefs d'entreprise mais il y a aussi des
gens qui cherchent des emplois qui
peuvent grâce aux réseaux sociaux en
trouver ben on a effectivement créé un
atelier avec Pôle Emploi un partenariat
avec Pôle emploi qui vise à accompagner
ce qui veut être mon boss qui
accompagner des jeunes demandeurs
d'emploi
pour trouver le job qui les fait vibrer
donc effectivement l'objectif c'est de
construire un plan d'action avec eux une
stratégie numérique on définit la cible
la cible des employeurs qui les
intéressent donc vous les formez
exactement et on les forme à l'usage de
LinkedIn et on les accompagne pour aller
inviter solliciter des patrons rédiger
des postes tous les jours
alterner les contenus
vidéo-créer graphiques ou post écrit et
ça fonctionne
leur faites rencontrer en gros des des
entreprises qui cherchent des
employés c'est ça l'idée c'est de faire
un listing effectivement des entreprises
des intérêts voilà des boss et des bons
interlocuteurs et ensuite d'avoir toute
une stratégie de contenu qui va
permettre d'attirer l'attention de ses
employeurs et c'est vrai que on a fait
on a fait des retours de témoignages
certains ont créé leur compte le lundi
le mercredi leur poste des 5000 vues et
ils avaient trois entretiens d'embauche
donc c'est vrai que on se rend compte
sur des gens qui ont cherché un emploi
pendant six mois au préalable et j'avais
rien trouvé donc c'est vrai que le
résultat est assez instantané et cette
proximité aussi qu'on a puisque on
arrive à communiquer avec des gens en
messagerie directement permet vraiment
un des résultats immédiats c'est
vraiment Pierre Olivier
sur les étudiants on essaye bon ils sont
sensibles à l'outil à LinkedIn et on a
une approche une approche un petit peu
ludique des choses les guides un
avantage ou un inconvénient selon si on
regarde c'est le SSI le social selling
index en fait c'est un score c'est un
score qui est calculé par l'algorithme
de Linkedin entre 0 et 100 et qui vous
donne finalement votre niveau de
performance
sur le réseau social et vu par le réseau
social mais en tout cas c'est une photo
qui est très intéressante pour un
entrepreneur et un étudiant puisque un
instant ça vous dit ok tu es à 35 sur
fort de ce constat maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire comme plan d'action pour
améliorer ce score et améliorer ce score
ça veut dire finalement améliorer sa
visibilité sur le réseau social et donc
générer des opportunités commerciales et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
un score qui est basé à la fois sur la
qualité de l'information qui est mise
sur son profil qui est basé sur le
réseau de contacts que l'on a sur
l'interaction vous parliez du fait de
d'avoir deux postes par semaine ces deux
postes il faut les faire vivre et puis
surtout sur la fidélité parce que notre
réseau on va communiquer avec lui on va
interagir avec lui dans le temps et si
par exemple on commence à partager des
postes et vous Patrice vous arrêtez de
les de les regarder je vais perdre des
points parce que finalement j'ai pas su
vous attirer dans la durée et donc c'est
un indicateur rigolo
[Rires]
et commenter sur toi je crois que c'est
oui ce que vous disiez quand un
pour qu'il soit
vu un grand nombre de gens et pour qu'il
est justement un bon score il faut le
commenter il faut il suffit pas de le
liker il faut aussi comment te mettre
son petit commentaire ajouter son petit
commentaire c'est ça en tout cas
effectivement pour maintenir sa
visibilité il faut effectivement qu'il
ait des commentaires l'enjeu c'est aussi
de créer des conversations on a tendance
aussi à croire que simplement une
tribune et donc qui est descendante en
créant des postes dans ma ravi de vous
partager et en fait il faut ouvrir le
dialogue avec les gens pour que ça
puisse la discussion puisse se maintenir
et donc le poste reste visible longtemps
mais ça c'est l'enjeu ah oui parce qu'on
voit sur beaucoup de gens qui font
c'est pas des sortes des sortes de
d'édito de choses comme ça qu'on
retrouve
ce que je pense de ceci ou de cela on
trouve ça beaucoup ça c'est ça peut
ouvrir une discussion évidemment mais
enfin l'idée au départ c'est plutôt de
communiquer avec les autres c'est ça
et donc il y a pas toujours un dialogue
qui s'enclenche mais sur les postes en
tout cas il faut effectivement
tout le monde et donc ensuite l'enjeu
c'est de les faire revenir de les faire
consommer de les faire évidemment
s'abonner au premium etc donc du coup il
faut effectivement qu'il y ait cette
interaction cette sollicitation
permanente se connecter en permanence
toute la journée et donc le dialogue
c'est ce qui est mieux est-ce que dans
les entreprises
de la CPME
vous avez ce que disait Olivier Pierre
Olivier des gens qui sont qui ont
commencé et puis qui se désespèrent un
peu en disant bah ça marche pas quoi
enfin alors
c'est sûr ça demande une certaine
rigueur donc ça veut dire que au début
on s'attend à avoir tout de suite du
succès quand on se met à LinkedIn on va
faire notre premier poste on va se dire
ça y est je vais avoir on va dire une
centaine de personnes en plus qui va me
suivre j'ai posté mon premier poste
alors parfois ça arrive félicitations
c'est pas tous les jours le cas c'est
vrai que on a des postes du coup qui
vont fonctionner on va toucher 1000 2000
3000 personnes et des postes qui sent
vraiment comprendre pourquoi
l'algorithme n'aura pas spécialement mis
en avant ce poste on va toucher parfois
moins de personnes et c'est vrai que
lorsque on accumule on va dire 1 2 3
postes qui ne fonctionnent pas super
c'est vrai qu'il y a certaines
entreprises qui commencent à perdre on
va dire un peu espoir entre guillemets
par rapport à LinkedIn alors que
pourtant c'est un travail de fond c'est
un travail de récurrence il faut
travailler son profit une fois qu'on a
travaillé le profil on fait à peu près
deux publications par semaine 2 à 3
publications par semaine avec certaines
astuces qu'on peut mettre en place pour
justement booster le nombre de vues
qu'on a sur nos postes et en même temps
voir ce que ça peut donner par la suite
donc oui on a pas mal d'entreprises qui
qui s'intéressent à LinkedIn et
certaines après bon c'est le travail de
rigueur qui qui ont tendance à lâcher
par la suite mais c'est pas c'est pas
les plus nombreuses
ça fait un petit moment que vous
enseignez
est-ce que les étudiants que vous avez
aujourd'hui sont quand même beaucoup
plus familiarisés à ce genre de
communication qui a même 4 ou 5 ans
alors plus familiarisé j'aurais tendance
à dire oui
avec un mais pour leur faire plaisir
parce qu'ils ont l'impression que c'est
facile même Instagram Instagram j'y vais
j'utilise sur mon profil etc si vous
voulez savoir ce que je fais pendant les
vacances mais alors maintenant on parle
d'outils professionnels et là
c'est différent comme le disait Melvin
il y a un accompagnement derrière il
faut vraiment avoir les bons outils le
bon accompagnement et là il ne mesure
pas encore donc c'est au travers des
cours c'est au travers on pourrait quand
ils sont en entreprise de la mise en
application et des formations qui
suivent qui vont se rendre compte du
sérieux mais un point est un et certains
c'est qu'entre leur dire on fait un
exercice de prospection téléphonique et
on fait un exercice de prospection sur
Linkedin j'en ai 9 sur 10 qui vont
partir faire de la prospection sur
LinkedIn et je pense que celui qui qui
n'est pas parti c'est qu'il a pas
entendu la question ça les intéresse ils
sont passionnés c'est sûr alors vous
disiez oui voilà avant de avant de se
lancer il faut définir savoir ce qu'on
veut dire
pourquoi
et justement
comment on fait beau alors vous dites
faut définir sa marque professionnelle
il faut il faut déjà aussi
dialoguer peut-être avec les gens qui
peuvent être intéressés par votre
démarche alors comment on fait l'avant
l'avant entrer dans le dans les réseaux
sociaux l'avant d'entrer dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est c'est la réponse
comment je me mets à nu ouais faut que
je fasse un beau strip-tease pour donner
envie parce que si j'enlève mes
vêtements ça va être un peu un peu
rapide et donc c'est un petit c'est ce
que vous disiez c'est finalement la
création de son storytelling de
l'histoire que je vais raconter à ma
cible j'ai lancé mon entreprise
finalement c'était cette idée est née
comment quel lien avec moi et ce que je
vais partager et finalement on va
tourner le profil de Linkedin
c'est-à-dire l'information qu'on va
partager autour de ce travail
préparatoire qui est la définition de
son storytelling de son histoire etc et
finalement c'est ça peut se ce qui va
aussi intéresser notre notre cible et
comme la cible va commencer à être
intéressée il va y avoir un effet de un
effet de buzz et de partage alors c'est
autre partie vous avez communiqué mais
comment
[Musique]
on parlait de cette mise à nu entre
guillemets
mais vous vous assistez vous beaucoup
sur l'idée que il faut peut-être au-delà
des objectifs qu'on peut avoir de
présenter une entreprise de présenter ce
qu'on ce qu'on fait ce dont on a besoin
ce qu'on a besoin de financement etc il
faut savoir raconter une histoire
c'est 69% de nos échanges globaux dans
la vie sont des histoires c'est-à-dire
qu'on vit dans un monde d'histoire
d'ailleurs on nous a raconté des
histoires petits et c'est ce qui nous a
aussi fait rêver ce qui a contribué à
notre enfance donc
en fait on est tous plus sensibles si je
vous dis si je vous dis je on est les
meilleurs commerçants c'est pas la même
chose que si je vous raconte que petite
je cueillais des fleurs et je les
revendais au fleuriste et que ça faisait
partie de mon histoire ça puis pas le
même la même manière et c'est pas c'est
pas la même crédibilité ensuite
effectivement on parlait tout à l'heure
de comment on démarre je de construire
ce qu'on appelle mon personnel branding
donc c'est ma marque personnelle c'est
mon identité c'est c'est le fait d'être
référent sur un sujet et
véhiculer certains messages et le
storytelling c'est l'art de bien
raconter ces histoires et d'emmener des
gens avec des épisodes vous l'avez dit
le strip-tease d'un coup ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est de toute manière la
communication c'est une séduction
et la communication
et c'est petit à petit il faut tenir les
gens en haleine on sait d'ailleurs que
sur les postes il y a des techniques des
titres qui disent tout si vous avez déjà
dit dans le titre du film déjà vous
annoncez la fin du film bon évidemment
ça va moins donner envie d'aller
regarder le film donc il faut savoir
créer un peu de suspense savoir séduire
il faut savoir tout j'ai trouvé des bons
mots qui touchent le registre des
émotions qui résonnent qui résonnent en
notre cible encore une fois et donc
évidemment je prône l'usage de
l'histoire de se servir de nos faits de
certains faits de vrais passé pour
servir certains messages de l'entreprise
et pour en tout cas les raconter de
notre manière que simplement et dire je
suis en fait l'histoire c'est ça mettre
une sorte on parle de roman national
pour la politique là c'est un roman
personnel un peu pour les réseaux
sociaux c'est ça c'est important c'est
important et un point aussi qui est
important ne pas mentir ah oui bah
raconter n'importe quoi parce que si
vous n'avez pas vendu de fleurs étant
petite
et que on s'en aperçoit vous perdez
toute crédibilité donc
justement pour pouvoir aller chercher ce
registre des émotions faut quand même
travailler sur des vrais faits parce
qu'en fait pour qu'une histoire soit
crédible il faut aussi qu'il y ait
certains détails il faut certains
éléments que seul vous avez et parce que
cette histoire est vrai et donc c'est
aussi quand on raconte un livre sont les
petits détails qui font qu'on se
projeter dans la scène et que l'histoire
paraîtrait sinon elle est elle est peu
crédible aussi de la même manière
exactement
à sa place on voit quand même que un
poste qui raconte une histoire c'est
quand même quelque chose de plus
passionnant à lire plutôt que un texte
de fond où c'est assez linéaire bonjour
je suis je fais voilà ce que je vous
propose alors que si on le tourne sous
une histoire comme par exemple il
m'arrivait un truc de fou aujourd'hui en
première ligne et puis ensuite par la
suite du poste on commence à raconter le
fond du message c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui aura tendance à quand
même bien plus fonctionner sur LinkedIn
et on va dire la pertinence et les
résultats des postes le
vous écrivez d'ailleurs dans le
l'article dans ce que les autres
preneurs constatent que leurs abonnés
sont principalement intéressés par leur
authenticité et de suivi de leur projet
entrepreneurial c'est un peu c'est un
peu ça exactement ce que je dis il faut
pas raconter des cracks
un peu surprise de voilà j'ai ce matin
signé un nouveau contrat grâce à et puis
on fait un lien avec un poste précédent
ou une anecdote et là ah bah tiens ça
c'est sympa
est-ce que
est-ce que c'est très individuel
évidemment cette communication mais
est-ce qu'on pouvait la plusieurs est-ce
que des des j'ai pas des entreprises
peuvent se regrouper pour pour poster
des choses qui seraient plus fortes que
si on en est seul
c'est à dire je sais pas qui sont dans
le même secteur
est-ce que ça pourrait arriver ça arrive
relativement peu me semble-t-il mais
dans les postes c'est vrai que ce qui
est important c'est quand même de de
d'interagir avec d'autres et d'inclure
d'autres personnages dans l'histoire si
on est tout le temps le héros il y a
aussi un moment donné où l'histoire va
laisser donc il y a un moment donné où
d'ailleurs juste pour revenir sur cette
notion de poste dans les top postes 2022
c'était tous les postes qui parlaient
des erreurs donc quand on parle
d'authenticité on a envie de savoir que
vous réussissiez mon envie de savoir
aussi parfois vous tombez et de savoir
comment vous êtes relevé donc c'est
c'est intéressant donc il y a cette
notion d'humanisation de très forte
volonté d'authenticité effectivement il
faut inclure les autres et pas
s'autocentrer sur soi-même avec sa
propre histoire et ses états d'âme parce
qu'au bout d'un moment ça laisse votre
cible il faut évidemment montrer que
vous êtes dans un écosystème dans un
environnement et qui il y a d'autres
personnes et quand on n'arrive pas à
parler de soi aussi la meilleure manière
c'est aussi parler des autres j'ai
rencontré ce client mais qu'est-ce qui
m'a plu chez ce client et qu'est-ce que
j'ai vécu avec lui et qu'est-ce qui m'a
partagé c'est aussi ça on peut aussi
raconter l'histoire de l'autre et de
l'inclure dans cette histoire en tout
cas pour et en plus on multiplie les
réseaux et la visibilité quand on écrit
donc
récepteurs enfin des messages parce que
vous pouvez avoir vous pouvez avoir des
gens que vous connaissez bien et que
vous aimez bien vous disiez et il faut
on peut commenter les postes c'est bien
quand on voilà quand on est clients
d'une entreprise qu'on aime bien on est
sur Linkedin il poste c'est bien de
relier les postes qu'ils ont créé oui
c'est toujours bien effectivement c'est
une bonne action et si j'ai un conseil
que je disais d'ailleurs sur mon poste
LinkedIn conseil à dire si vous avez un
ami qui est entreprend un qui lance son
projet relayer son poste likez commentez
relayer c'est le meilleur service que
vous puissiez lui rendre pour se lancer
et ça on y pense pas beaucoup d'amis qui
me disent ben non moi je ne fais que
regarder et je like et je ne like rien
bah ouais mais c'est vrai que n'oublie
pas l'impact d'un like et d'un partage
pour celui qui se lance et qui a besoin
de ça c'est vraiment le premier canal le
canal gratuit le canal le plus puissant
aujourd'hui et donc voilà s'il y a un
geste à faire c'est évidemment
peut-être
un petit bémol vous disiez voilà il faut
faire au moins une heure par jour par
exemple sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce
qu'il y a pas le risque au contraire que
ça bouffe à leur tour du temps contre se
consacre trop à ça on oubliant au fond
le le fond de son activité et puis les
autres moyens de communication alors il
y a un risque on parle je parlais tout à
l'heure du social selling index ce score
qui va bouger tous les deux trois jours
il y en a qui tous les jours vous
regardez plusieurs fois dans la journée
punaises punaise oui un phénomène qui va
être je me prends au jeu et je me prends
plus au jeu de continuer à améliorer mon
ma communication mon profil que
finalement l'impact que sa voix que ça
va avoir sur mon sur mon business donc
c'est trouver le bon milieu et si on est
seul il y a ce risque d'où l'intérêt
aussi de d'être accompagné
les entrepreneurs ont des environnements
qui sont on va dire très favorables des
incubateurs beaucoup de conseils qui
leur sont donnés pour justement prendre
du recul par rapport à ça
c'est important de préciser
qu'effectivement il y a un phénomène
addictif et qu'effectivement
il y a le il y a l'ego
quand on a un truc qui est repris très
heureux voilà tout le monde est content
quoi social c'est que quand je publie si
personne là et que j'ai l'impression que
ce que j'ai dit c'est pas important
c'est pas intéressant et en fait ça met
des doutes et c'est vrai que du coup il
y a un phénomène effectivement ça sert
aussi toute notre partie narcissique qui
est de se dire aussi voilà je m'expose
je parle de moi et finalement personne
n'approuve personne ne soutient ce que
j'ai écrit donc
moi-même je me suis déjà vu passer
parfois plus de temps que prévu sur
Linkedin pour préparer un poste
réfléchir à exactement ce que je vais
dire comment faire alors du coup il y a
toute une idée enfin toute une réflexion
à faire sur la rédaction savoir
exactement le visuel donc c'est vrai que
parfois c'est assez chronophage mais
après si on arrive à bien on va dire
cadrer le LinkedIn savoir combien de
temps combien de temps doit faire ça
avec l'expertise on arrive à rentrer
dans les temps sans aucun problème et
c'est quelque chose on va dire de très
utile
je vous cite la conclusion de votre
article de
l'usage des réseaux sociaux requiert
surtout une bonne gestion de son temps
de la rigueur dans son approche de
l'agilité dans sa communication et les
échanges fréquents à la fois avec sa
communauté d'abonnés et avec d'autres
entrepreneurs afin de capitaliser sur le
retour d'expérience parce qu'on a soudé
avec ça mais c'est du bon sens encore
faut-il arriver maintenant à le mettre
en pratique exactement alors justement
vous disiez les les entrepreneurs comme
ça ils découvrent ça ils ont du mal ils
possèdent pas forcément tous les tous
les codes ben justement on va poser les
questions de est-ce qu'il y a besoin de
se former aux réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
alors Virginie je me tourne vers vous
parce que vous êtes votre job de former
avec StarTAC
comment d'abord vous est venu l'idée
d'ailleurs de créer cette entreprise et
cette entreprise de formation
j'ai toujours travaillé dans le
numérique donc c'est ma troisième
société dans le numérique
et après j'ai toujours formé donc je
suis intervenue dans beaucoup de grands
groupes
d'écoles enfin tous ces écoles de la
tech depuis 2010 et puis et puis dans
dans mon ADN dans mon histoire
effectivement je n'aimais pas beaucoup
l'école je n'étais pas très assidue
parce que je me déconseille très
facilement et donc ce que j'aimais
c'était la pratique j'adorais toutes les
d'ailleurs toutes les matières
professionnelles pratiques et donc quand
j'ai créé star tag j'ai eu envie de
monter un centre de formation ou on fait
on se lance on tombe parfois mais on se
relève et on est là pour accompagner des
gens à finalement testé travailler
s'améliorer en faisant et donc on a j'ai
créé la 33 modules de formation coffret
avec des intervenants on a plus d'une
trentaine de formateurs qui sont qui
sont sélectionnés parce qu'on ce sont
des gens qui pratiquent et qui
pratiquent avec évidemment des belles
performances personne chez nous de dire
le cordonnier le plus mal chaussé il
fait il a des exemples concrets il a
essayé il s'est parfois loupé
qui se forme alors il y a les
entreprises il y a les salariés il y a
il y a tout le monde il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises et tous secteurs
d'activité on travaille dans des
domaines que ce soit dans l'industrie
dans le service dans la com
on a tout même dans l'outillage on a
vraiment des secteurs d'activités très
variés on en a tous besoin aujourd'hui
il y a pas une entreprise qui a pas
besoin d'être présent sur les réseaux
sociaux qui a pas besoin d'établir une
stratégie numérique qui a pas besoin de
travailler ça irréputation etc donc on
forme tout le monde et également
effectivement des entrepreneurs qui se
lancent faut savoir aussi qu'il y a des
dispositifs de prise en charge de
formation pour les entrepreneurs qui
sont méconnus et c'est vrai que
intéressantes ils peuvent donc financer
leur formation et évidemment de toute
manière c'est des formations qu'on doit
mettre à jour régulièrement puisque
c'est évolue très très vite Melvin
vous êtes formés vous-même tout à fait
alors par le biais de différents
ateliers qui ont été mis en place avec
la CPME et du coup Virginie qui est
intervenu nous a donné plein de petits
tips et astuces savoir exactement
comment LinkedIn fonctionne ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut pas faire en
fait mettre les règles du jeu quoi par
rapport à ça et du coup oui oui je peux
dire que je on va dire je suis formé
dessus j'ai appris ouais je me je
l'utilise l'outil maintenant depuis un
certain temps presque un an et c'est sûr
que on apprend avec la formation et
ensuite on append sur le tas et les
retours que vous avez des des
entreprises des gens qui se sont formés
on va parler tout à l'heure des gens qui
à la recherche d'emploi alors pour eux
c'est évidemment ça a changé leur vie
puisque ils ont trouvé un emploi alors
qu'ils étaient parfois laissé de côté
mais les entreprises aussi
ça change un peu leur façon de
fonctionner de façon unanime tous disent
avoir franchi une étape d'ailleurs tous
renouvelle après avec d'autres et
poursuivre les formations avec d'autres
sujets mais moi j'adore à la fin des
formations LinkedIn parce que il est
toujours le côté les yeux qui brillent
en disant ok mon poste a fait 5 10 000
vues j'ai eu un contact mais quelqu'un
que je connaissais mais normalement il
est censé savoir ce que je fais il me
contacte comme s'il était surpris de
découvrir mon activité bah oui en fait
on est dans la vie de tous les jours on
va dans des soirées dans des événements
personnels on parle pas toujours son job
LinkedIn ça permet aussi d'avoir une
tribune et moi j'ai des gens qui 25 ans
après la me contactent notamment été au
collège ensemble je suis tout époque je
sais que tu es la référence dans le
numérique et je te contacte parce que je
te pose dans telle boîte et j'aimerais
que pour nos équipes on puisse former du
monde donc finalement c'est aussi
créateur de lien et donc forcément on
sent très très vite les résultats qui
sont immédiats puisque aujourd'hui c'est
des communications instantanées de
proximité puisque le téléphone aussi a
poussé ses usages là encore une fois au
réveil en mangeant tous les moments de
la vie quoi donc exactement
à vos à vos étudiants ou à vos ou aux
entreprises que vous conseillez mais
pensez que c'est c'est nécessaire cette
formation c'est indispensable déjà les
étudiants on leur donne un maximum de
cours de conseils sur le numérique sur
le digital sur le gros saking sur le sur
les réseaux sociaux etc pour qu'ils
soient opérationnel mais ce que l'on
voit c'est qu'au bout de deux ans tout
ce qu'on a pu leur dire c'est déjà
quasiment obsolète donc le fait que
derrière ça va très vite et ça va être
extrêmement vite là on parle de Linkedin
peut-être que dans deux ans il y aura un
autre réseau à notre réseau donc c'est
important qu'ils aient une formation
initiale opérationnelle et surtout que
régulièrement il soit amené à être aidé
à accompagné dans leur carrière et puis
il y a
et on le voit et c'est pour ça qu'on a
poussé la pratique c'est que parfois
sont des freins psychologiques à se
lancer et il y a une prise de confiance
en soi qu'il faut avoir on se dit
toujours j'ai rien à dire je sais pas
quoi dire je sais pas comment le faire
tout le monde va me juger il y a ce côté
là et parfois d'être accompagné juste
pour franchir la première marche ça
enclenche parce que ça casse un peu les
croyances limitantes un mot pour
conclure
on parlait de l'entreprise et donc je
disais il y a dans les entreprises qui
se créent il y a des entreprises il y a
des petites entreprises des grandes
entreprises
certains ont la possibilité d'engager
des spécialistes c'est ce que c'est bien
d'engager un communauté manager si on
peut le faire un comité manager
effectivement comme son nom l'indiqué il
va travailler la communauté il va poster
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ne pas être
présent sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
très compliqué parce que quand bien même
certains me disent
faut en faire une spécificité il faut se
vendre comme n'étant pas sur les réseaux
sociaux peut-être si vous choisissez de
payer être quelqu'un d'autre parlera de
vous à votre place alors est-ce que vous
préférez prendre la parole vous préférez
que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre qui parle
de vous ensuite est-ce qu'il faut tout
déléguer un community manager attention
il y a des cibles il y a des secteurs
d'activité et si on en parle sur des
secteurs B2B ou il suffit pas simplement
de poster pour enfin poster des postes
sur l'actualité de l'entreprise il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin il faut faire
juste attention au calibrage et au fond
parce qu'on peut pas faire que des des
postes un peu superficiel il faut aller
aussi dans du fond pour prouver sa
crédibilité son expertise et donc il
faut bien choisir en tout cas le comité
manager ou faut bien le former à ce
qu'il est aussi une culture et une
approche en rapport avec la cible encore
une fois exactement si vous adressez à
des grands décideurs vous n'avez pas
communiquer de la même manière que si
vous vendez des affaires enfin vous
faites du BIT aussi et que ce sont des
vêtements à La Redoute enfin je veux
dire l'approche n'est pas la même donc
il faut il faut bien calibrer ça c'est
une bonne conclusion parce que ça va
vous boucle la boucle puisque c'est ce
que vous disiez au début bah faut savoir
ce qu'on veut dire et pourquoi donc
voilà
travailler les réseaux sociaux formés
vous on sait comme ça TOI
très bien
stratégie marketing c'est son fils
que vous publiez avec Maëlys bulk et
puis Pierre
Olivier Gifa l'entrepreneuriat c'est
c'est
Emma édition c'est exactement c'est un
hasard on se connaissait pas
merci merci à tous les trois merci mes
amis peut-être et puis pendant parler un
jour de la CPME parce que c'est
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de petites et
moyennes entreprises sur ce territoire
énormément énormément sur le territoire
avec les Yvelines avec le covid et
autres il y en a tellement qui se sont
développés bah sujet d'actualité les
réseaux sociaux du coup il faut se
mettre dessus pour développer la
visibilité donc pas de souci merci merci
à tous et puis à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]